you know cain killed abel you know and  uh you know that's the problem that we  have and i said what we need to do is  look into how we can stop those things  you know they talked about doing a  disinformation what about getting a  department that can look at young men  that's looking at are women that looking  at uh just social media what okay  what about getting a department  that's looking at young men  that's looking at women  that's looking at social media  this could be one of 100 senators  and  i want to be sensitive to  the mental illness component  the brain injury component  but this is just fundamentally  humiliating  this is the winner of the primary